i remember watching magic school bus in
school do you remember is it medically
accurate we're about to find out bee woo
what are you doing
our class is broadcasting two hours of
live television today and i said i'd
have a show for them to do and i don't
yet
that's how i feel making every youtube
video and cover your mouth when you're
coughing buddy it's my opinion as your
mother and as a doctor that you have a
fever which means you are sick which
means you are going back to bed how did
she know he has a fever she did not
measure his temperature she did not feel
his forehead yes dr tinelli thank you
for calling what is this stegosaurus
that's on top of her shoulder is ralphy
staying home from school today miss
frizzle i can't overstate the importance
of this do not send your kids to school
if they are sick then it prevents the
other kids from getting sick too
how can anything that smells like grape
shoe polish help my body get well
spoiler alert it doesn't coughs here
doesn't really help you get better and
in fact when we look at the research at
over-the-counter cough syrups they don't
work that well just use some magical
honey as long as you're over the age of
one why am i saying it to you as if
you're one and you understand what i'm
saying and don't forget to shake well
before using
like this
even your jokes are sick
wow
wow stand up comedy i've got to go see
another patient but grandpa's downstairs
if you need anything okay mama bear
you're a doctor you know that if you're
kissing your son who is sick you're
potentially getting yourself sick
thereby getting your patients sick
don't do that good
is the afternoon news network i need to
know what this brontosaurus is
[Music]
the fnn news team is nearing the
disaster area okay so they're in the oro
pharynx here they're by the uvula a
little punching bag that hangs from the
back of your throat it looks like
they're going low to check out the
tonsils the pharynx maybe even the
larynx if they go lower enough ah get a
shot of those vocal cords class look how
red and swollen his throat is most kids
when they have a sore throat it's not
their vocal cords that are the problem
it's usually higher up tonsils which is
why you hear tonsillitis or pharyngitis
which is just your typical sore throat
but that is higher than the layering so
i don't know why they ventured all the
way down to the larynx it's not as easy
for us or germs to get inside the body
as you might think yeah skin pretty much
covers it yo what is this pterodactyl
that's just in every scene i've got it
the nose
look at this is it just me what does
this say this way in
how are you gonna get into the
mouth
through a scab on your thigh that is one
journey the magic school bus probably
won't make we're all gonna die
it's a shortcut get it shortcut carlos
i love puns carlos not a good pun
wow dude what is this triceratops doing
someone tell me for every trip there's a
road map
that's ralphie's bloodstream good
bloodstream
we'll take the trans-ralphie highway
system and here we go
[Music]
what does it make sense to me is let's
say they take the venus system back up
to his throat the venous system doesn't
empty at his throat it hit these into
the heart in order to get to the throat
they need to take the venous system back
to the heart from the heart back up to
the throat and then from the capillaries
kind of enter the throat
diffusion
and it doesn't even hurt this kid's not
panicking there's a velociraptor sitting
next to it
they ventured into a capillary those are
red blood cells floating around
platelets white blood cells floating in
there as well that stuff is clear that's
right rafi
the liquid part of the blood is clear
it's actually not clear it's yellow it's
plasma we talked about this if you
haven't video linked down below are they
what made blood what is this
ankylosaurus doing watching television
and filming they're called red blood
cells
and the white ones are white blood cells
but what are those jaggedy things
platelets
maintenance they help the body heal
scrapes and cuts that's true blood has
the four components there platelets
white blood cells red blood cells and
plasma plasma makes up 55 of your blood
and it's yellow so your blood's really
yellow bacteria are germs what's inside
our bodies they can make us sick
ralphie has a bacterial infection what a
great diagnosis and that's absolutely
true bacterial infections do make us
sick they can give us sore throats
that's why you hear the term strep
throat sore throats the majority of time
aren't caused by bacterial infections
are caused by viruses therefore not
requiring antibiotics such an important
point look here comes white blood cells
it's throwing stuff in the bacteria
[Music]
basically what happens is the bacteria
gets labeled as foreign it starts
getting attacked and eaten alive by the
macrophages the neutrophils start
multiplying in number and through an
inflammatory cascade you actually call
on more white blood cells to come on and
beat up on this bacteria but then
remember when you're having this
inflammatory cascade it's also causing
damage to the surrounding tissue the way
i like to explain this is imagine a war
just went on on some really beautiful
grass and even though the good guys won
and they're all safe and sound the grass
got pretty torn up that's your throat
that's what needs time to heal that's
why it hurts
no wonder i'm there's a spinosaurus
hiding underneath his blanket i'm going
to try to get an exclusive interview
with these two bacteria if you ever run
into a bacteria do not interview it
they will infect you
and [ __ ] you complete i just saw a
guanogan pop up
[Music]
the plesiosaur just turned on the
television is that the medicine mom gave
me earlier it sure is okay take back
what i said it looks like the mom slash
doctor gave him an antibiotic how did
she know it was bacterial i don't know
because she didn't do a strep test she
didn't do a throw culture i feel like
this is encouraging to overuse of
antibiotics but maybe i'm taking it too
seriously because it's a cartoon i mean
what i think it means oh no
ralph is anybody so mark the bus is back
the macro she's about to eat the magic
school bus
why isn't apothesaurus waking ralphie up
so he can save them ralphie's white
blood cells will have to catch us first
it's a good thing bacteria don't have
hovercraft engines or turbines on the
back of them to escape whiteboard cells
i've never seen a tyrannodon use an
alarm clock before this is certainly a
first
[Music]
this brachiosaurus is really getting
witty we left ralphy's throat and are
now heading up his nasopharyngeal
passages prediction time they're gonna
get clumped in a piece of mucus and
they're going to get sneezed right out
final answer
[Music]
they're like throat cool nose ew what's
the difference
[Music]
is the mosasaurus sneezing can you get
inter-species infectivity like this
i get it i've gotta sneeze them out but
i don't feel like sneezing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this diplodocus is one smart dino
sorry liz but i can't hear a thing do
dilophosauruses even have lungs getting
all your shots is another way to keep
healthy shots help your body be prepared
for some of the really tough germs a
vaccine is like a wanted poster where
you essentially tell all your cells to
be ready for this foreign invader in
case it does come along
[Music]
no way
she takes good care of herself gets all
of her shots and she's magic
i don't think that's an accurate
representation to kids it's okay to get
sick you will get better the body needs
challenges without challenges that's how
autoimmune problems happen
medical shows are fun but medical games
are even more fun check out this video
of me playing surgeon simulator i make a
really good surgery not accurate but
very fun to watch click here check it
out as always stay happy at home
operation
[Music]
[Applause]
you